good morning uh
this is our last morning i wanted to
thank the organizers so i thought this
was a
really great workshop and uh
glad i came
um
so let's see for uh
let me just start by reminding
reminding you what the problem was
those of you if there are those of you
who didn't see my original talk
this should be fairly self-contained
um
we've got this
kind of unusual communication game we've
got alice and bob
and alice is getting
his input
permutation
of one through n
and it's being streamed
sigma one segment two
and alice is
as a vector
within positions
and
when she gets sigma one
she's allowed to write in position sigma
1 a bit
and when she gets sigma 2 she can write
a bit in this position
and she can't go back
and change anything she's written
and when sigma n arrives
alice does not get to write what she
wants she has to write
b which is
the bit that comes in the stream
and then when alice is all done bob gets
to see the vector
and bob has to output
the subset j in one through n
and the requirement is that sigma n
the last thing in the permutation has to
appear
has to be intersect j
and the cost
of this protocol
on this particular input
is
the size of j
and what we're interested in is the
worst case cost overall
so all
so
the cost of the protocol
is
the max
over sigma and b
we can think of j the set that bob
outputs as a function of
sigma and b
um
it'll be the worst case size
okay so any questions about the problem
now yesterday i told you why one would
want to consider such a thing if you
weren't here yesterday
you'll have to read the paper i'm not
going to spend time on that so we'll
just assume yeah so if you can prove
anything about the average case
complexity does that give anything to
you
well
so again everything
if you prove
all you need to prove is a lower bound
on
so it's easier that's right so we can
define
you know the value vn
is the
minimum overall protocols
of the max
over
segment b of the cost
which is
and um i could replace
i'll call vnbar
submin overall protocols
of the average
and the
injector hypothesis whatever you
want is that uh
there exists the delta
such that v n
is greater than or equal to n to the
delta
and obviously a stronger conjecture
then i mentioned a couple of other
conjectures
so if you're in the rand if you're in
the average case setting once you fix a
protocol
then
you could look at
how much does
bob learn about the
sigma n
given the the
vector and i call this vector gamma
so
when you look at the
so under the
given that sigma and b come in randomly
you can look at what's the residual
entropy of sigma and given gamma
it's easy to see that this conjecture
would imply this one which implies this
one
and then i mentioned
so you could
change the game
by allowing
alice to write instead of a binary
alphabet you give her a k a k letter
alphabet
and so you can now
um
well let's just go back to the worst
case one so i'll write v n k
which is the game with the k letter
alphabet
so you'd expect the larger you the
alphabet the smaller the lower bound
will be
but it still
seemed reasonable to guess that
increasing the alphabet to
a constant size they will still
be expensive
zero and as i mentioned yesterday
we really thought this one was true
but it's not
and
well we didn't know whether we thought
this one is true but this one is also
false
even for k equal three
and the behavior in fact
so
um
there is a protocol
such that uh h
that
and then also
for alphabet size k
let's say for alphabet size 3
vn3 is less than or equal to
order log n
and v in
k is
well log
and this by this i mean
the iterated logarithm so if i give you
an alphabet of size
10
then it's log log log
there are protocols that go into log log
log
um
so to prove the conjecture you just need
to show that the entropy is positive
right
what type anything bigger than zero
would be good enough to prove the
conjecture uh no why
what for the
oh
okay the size determines the size of
right i mean oh you know the if the
mutual if this residual entropy
is this then you get
a bound here of two to this power
so now you don't okay if you don't know
anymore
i'm asking is there a way to frame an
entropy no i don't have an entropy
conjecture that implies
so this
sort of
i mean one of the basics for basis the
basic intuition that implies
unfortunately it's not true yeah i mean
it is possible that there may be yet
another entropy version
that would imply it because there's
still some information theoretic
intuition floating around here which
maybe one could turn into a
a statement that one could prove but
this is what we tried and
turned out not to be true
okay
so
yeah and then i mentioned
so the protocols that do this
have a certain property
so yeah what i said yesterday was well
once you see these it sort of should it
certainly destroyed our
you know belief that this original
conjecture was true
the belief was i wouldn't say you
restored but at least
you know resurrected from the dead by
the following observation or the thought
which was that if you look at the
protocols which defeat these then they
have a certain
so
you know these
um
the above protocols
are
i'll call the monotone and i'll tell you
what that means i said it very quickly
yesterday i'll say it a little more
slowly now
our monotone and what we showed was
that
vn
call it m for monotone so if you go back
to the original thing and you restrict
yourself to a monotone protocol
then this is at least
something like square root n rounded
down i mean it's very
sharp so
the protocols that defeat these
strengthenings
definitely will not distribu defeat the
original conjecture
but we know a non-monotone protocol
that's the best we knows 0.99 is not
important so we know how to do something
a little better than square root n and
the protocol is non-monitored
these four these conjectures here
the thing that defeats them you know
ones
the thing that defeats them are monotone
protocols which i'll tell you what they
are in a minute
and then but
you know if you think so our thinking
was well
our reason for thinking this was true in
the first place was sort of
made it would
just as well lead us to believe that
these are true
these are false
but they're false for reasons that will
give you a monotone protocol for them
but if you now go back here so i don't
know exactly you know
you can draw whatever conclusions you
want from all this
um yeah i think i missed one step yes
what does alice has to descend to pop
during the entire vector yeah
but
does it make a difference whether n is
old or even or
uh no
let's give me a protocol what are the
values right one in assume the length is
ordered and you write ones in even
positions and zeros in old position
so that the last bit cannot be different
from it's adversarial the
adversary gives you the string he knows
your protocol and he
gives you the string okay
is that okay
does that answer the first five minutes
yesterday
okay
um
all right so there's a bunch of stuff i
got about uh 15 minutes
and all of these things each one of them
takes five minutes to explain but i
don't you know
five is five minutes
is really 10 but you know so i can't do
the i can't do them all
uh but let's
so
let me start by showing you the entropy
one because i think that's since we're
it's an information theory
theory workshop
okay so i want to show you a protocol
where at the end
the amount of uncertainty that bob has
about the last position
is very low
all right although what we'll see in
this protocol
v n for this protocol is still very big
in fact even vn bar
is going to be like n over log n or
something like that but uh okay so
what's the protocol
we're talking about
we're talking about uniform distribution
on strings right
uh on sigma yeah in segment
it's uniform
so i need to
let me say something which
i should make a remark so
what is a strategy this is uh i don't
need this for the
for the protocol but it's something to
have in mind what is what exactly
formally is a strategy for this thing
so you know at every step alice
alice is getting the permutation and she
has to decide what to write and what she
writes can depend on a bunch of stuff
she can write on it can depend on the
permutation she's seen so far
right now based on the permutations
she's seen so far she's she's has a
vector
you know she wrote
one here and zero here
and one here and everything else is
stars there's nothing here yet and now
the next thing comes in position i
and she looks at
you know these things
and there's also the order in which
these guys came
okay and what she writes here could in
principle depend on the order and on
what she wrote
and you know one little lemma is that
without loss of generality
the order in which these guys came
doesn't matter you can assume that what
she writes next depends on you know the
position that just came in and what's
already written here
but it doesn't matter what order these
things came in that's so that's a simple
lemma that you can prove that without
loss of generality you can restrict to
those strategies we call them in the
paper we call them
um
i guess order insensitive
protocols so they they they don't depend
on the order of the things that already
came they only depend on the subset and
what's actually written here so then her
strategy looks like this
you know for every partial assignment
and for every bit that's not assigned
then there's a specif you have to
specify
given this partial assignment and this
bit should you write zero or right once
okay so for so what it's a it's a
function
f sub i
for each eye so for all i
you know goes to either
0 or 1 where alpha is a partial
assignment
of all the bits of of some subset of the
bits
so this ranges over all partial
assignments in which i is not yet
assigned
okay is that clear so that's what a
strategy is
okay
um
okay so i'm going to tell you
what alice can do
to make bob's infra entropy really small
so i'm going to pick a parameter i'll
fix a parameter t and t will eventually
be
just a function
bob is a function which you look at the
from binary vectors to subsets
so the
the strategy is going to fix the
parameter t
which will eventually be log squared n
but we'll see what t has to be
and alice does the following thing for
the first n minus t steps
n minus t steps
alice writes
zero
that's pretty easy
okay now
now comes the work
so now there's t steps and t we'll see
in a minute t is going to be greater
than or equal to log n
so let's interpret
the index set
one through n
just by associating it as
so instead of the index set being one
through and the index set is
binary vectors of length
k and uh
so t is going to be i'll say bigger than
k so
i've written zeros here
let's assume you know just n is a power
of two so
we've got all vectors of length k if you
if you view these as vectors in gf2 to
the k then the sum of the vectors
zero
and
let's look at all the vectors
corresponding to where you've written
zero and that has a certain sum
and
we know that the sum of everything is
zero
and here's what alice does she looks at
what she hasn't filled in zeros yet
like each of these entries are vectors
and not
what no not the the index the indices
the label right the they were one
through n and now each thing is just
indexed
by and now i'm saying that
she's written 0
in certain places and just look at the
indices there and add them up mod 2
as vectors
we know that
the sum of everything is zero
so she looks at the indices she hasn't
written in yet and she identifies a
subset and the subset will be
the the
lexicographic the well she looks at um
the lexicographically smallest subset
of indices
which
combined with these sums to zero
okay so for example everything is good
yeah so for example if you you know
if you sum everything but you know you
could take subsets of these
and
uh
well i claimed that so let's see
um
what
you need most log n of them because
you know
look at the complement of what you
picked
so that will also sum to zero and if the
set that you chose
you know the whole you you have the set
that you have to combine with this
you can throw away anything that sums to
zero you can throw away anything that
sums to zero and there's if you've got
more than log n vectors then
okay so there's some set that you
identify which i'll call uh no you don't
go want to call it j because j is so
let's call it uh
s
so when you say lexicographic order the
lexicographic order is an increasing
order of set size
no so yeah i guess so yeah so yeah
smaller that's true
yeah so in other words you're going to
find the smallest set
which
this among first you say what's the size
of the smallest set that i can combine
with this to get zero
and then
subject to that i picked the one that's
lexicographically
smallest where i i ordered them now
according to the
you know some fixed ordering on the
vectors on the indices
not not this subset because bob is
another source
right
that's right
okay
and now what's the what does alice do
she's going to write
zeros
in the set s and she'll write ones
everywhere else
so she's going to have identified the
small subset of the remainder
there were two things left
and she's going to write one in the
things in s complement and zero
everywhere else
so that's the protocol
well she does she can't control the last
one
okay so now let's
let's see what's from bob's point of
view
so
bob
looks at the positions where he gets
ones
at the end
and he adds up the vectors corresponding
to those ones
and i claim
if the sum is non-zero
how could that happen
well
what
yeah means that there was a there was
something now
it could have been corrupt you know that
the last one was
should have been a one and it was
changed to a zero or the last one should
have been a zero and corrupted to a one
but in any case if you add those up and
you actually look at the vector mod two
that actually is the index that was
corrupted
that was the last one it has so in other
words if the sum is non-zero
it uniquely determines what the la what
sigma is and bob will be able to output
a set of size one
okay
and otherwise
so now the the
the harder case not not much harder is
the sum is zero
okay now
if the sum is zero then that could
happen in two ways well
you know
that means that
uh
the final bit b actually was what alice
wanted to write
now the final big b could have been a
zero or could have been a one
however
conditioned on
what is the probability that the last
bit
that arrived is one where alice wanted
to write a one
well it's
t minus the size of s
over t
because
alice you know s is the ones where alice
wants to write a zero
and that's s over t
and
think of t is a lot bigger than s
so with very with with high probability
the bit that arrives at the end is one
where alice wanted to write a one
okay so
if you work out now
so can if you look at the conditional
information what happens is it's highly
likely
so
let's just uh let's do this entropy
argument correctly
so
how much information what is the
information that bob needs in order to
now know how much more information so if
we're in one of two cases either the bit
that arrived at the end was one of the
things where
you wanted to write a zero or you wanted
to write a one so i first reveal
you know with one bit i can tell you in
which i can tell bob in which situation
you're in so i'm trying to bound the
the residual entropy
and i say well
i'll give away one bit by telling you
which situation you're in
now if you're in this situation
how much entropy is there
well there's actually a lot because
what i know that if this is the case
that the last bit that arrived is one of
the zeros almost everything is a zero
so in that case there's like log n bits
but the chance that this happens is only
s over t
in this case
well
how much information
then you know that it's one of the ones
and the amount of
entropy left is log t
and it's 1 minus
s over t
so let's ignore that here so you get you
know s over t log n s log n over t
plus log t
so
how should you choose t well how about
choose t equal log squared n
uh
what do you want yeah so if i choose
if i choose t to be
oh an s we said was log it was at most
log n
so if i choose t to be log squared n the
contribution here is just constant
and the contribution here is log log n
so the residual entropy is log is it
most log log n
okay i guess i don't have much time to
tell you anything else
uh
so
i just want to see if i can give a hint
uh
let me just tell you carefully what
monotone means
okay this protocol is monotone the other
protocols are monotone and then
that's all i'll i won't have time to
tell you much else um
so we said that each of these functions
fi
takes as input alpha and then outputs
you know either
0 or 1 or if the alphabet is larger zero
one or two
so
this is a partial assignment
let's look at the partial order on
partial assignments which says just
you know uh if you take a partial
assignment
and you change some stars to something
else then that's greater
and now i look at the function which
maps the partial assignment and i want
with respect to that partial order
it should be monotone
which means that initially when when
things are sparse you start you're going
to write zeros and then eventually
depending on what happens in alpha
you'll change you'll say oh well now if
i arrives i'll write a one in that
position
and then after a while you might change
and say i'll write a two in that
position
okay so
it's monotone in that sense okay and
it's easy to see this one's kind of
trivially monotone because in every
position you write a zero except at this
crucial stage you change and you say
okay and this set of positions i'll
write a one and then you never change
your mind again you're just going to
write it's just sort of fix it so this
one is trivially monotone
and i'll say that there's sort of
the protocol for the k thing is also
sort of it's there's a trivially
monotone protocol which works if your
alphabet size is three
so
you could of course change the
interpretation of zero and one
well you could
but i'm not sure what year
mean what looks like a monotone
and one interpretation may not look like
hormones
yeah so all i'm saying is the protocols
like the protocol i gave you is monotone
okay
and now the the result is if you
restrict yourself to monotone
protocols
then
for every for every monotone protocol
the worst case cost so the worst case
cost of this protocol is really bad
because there are situations where your
uncertainty is really big
i'm saying that that's actually true of
any monotone protocol the worst case
uncertainty is at least square root n
so
you know i'm not sure what to make of it
we can
we can defeat these stronger things but
we defeat them with protocols
which have a property that we know is
not enough to defeat the original
conjecture
okay
no and maybe there was no we didn't we
kind of gave up on entropy once but
maybe there should be
yeah
right so yeah i mean so
that is a
a direction that
has been in the back of our mind that we
should check sometime but we haven't
done it so
this hyper cube problem
freddy
so
suppose you have more than half
of the boolean cube a set s of more than
half the boolean q
then there's they study the problem of
um find a find a
vertex in this
set which has high degree within this
set
they prove that it's there's a vertex of
degree at least log in
roughly log in within the set
and um the conjecture that or it's the
problem is posed that maybe there's one
that's a degree at least n to the delta
for some delta so this is same thing for
proving that sensitivity of any function
is greater than login yeah yeah so the
the problem that i but it's not clear
that the conjectures go in the reverse
direction that's what in other words
that's why i'm not i'm not sure it's
true that a lower bound on vn implies a
lower bound on their problem
but i'm not convinced i mean maybe but
i'm
not convinced that the lower bound goes
on the opposite direction
i don't want you to miss your flight but
uh can you give us a hint about what
happens with the three symbols
or with that
um
yes i will give you try to do it in one
minute so in three symbols for the for
all but a hundred log n you're gonna say
zero
okay and just in the last login
so
what you want to do is
you're going to um
you want to to give
bob enough information so now there's a
set called the t elements left t is now
not log squared but
okay so you want bob to be able to
figure out
what that set is
okay now bob is almost gonna know that
set because you're gonna not write zeros
in that you're gonna write ones and twos
but maybe the adversary writes a zero in
the last position so there's some
uncertainty which is like an erasure
that the
and okay but what you can do is you're
going to use an error correcting code
to
be able to uh
enable him to sort of recover by looking
at what you write in these positions
to recover actually what that last
position was
okay well i don't you know so that's
roughly what you're gonna do
yeah by the way there is a paper on this
which was in uh
which was in itcs
and
it should be on one of our web pages but
i can't promise it is but i'll put it on
there so
um